[Music]
[Applause]
knock it off knock it off
oh man you're gonna be in my hotel room
later
happy Wednesday everyone it's the first
Wednesday of the new year and I can only
hope you're holding on to those
resolutions after all you want a beach
bod not a bankman bod
somebody get this guy a training bra
he's a 30 year old guy with the body of
Kathy Bates
founded Goldman Sachs huh see transition
everybody
as a recession becomes reality in
layoff's Loom the perks that one used to
enjoy at your job are disappearing
faster than Whoopi Goldberg's Jewish fan
base
according to the New York Post they're
taking away their free coffee perks for
the Goldman Sachs employees I know stop
the presses or at least the French
presses
I know
that's why I sit here and you're in the
audience
so now those bankers have to pay for it
like the rest of us just like I do for
those massages
Bill Hammer has such strong hands
sadly as the New York Post reports
Goldman Sachs employees return to work
on Tuesday to find out that they'd have
to pay for their crappy coffee that's
the post words not mine I'm guessing
it's Starbucks which I happen to like
because you know what I always say I
like my coffee the way I like my joy
read black and really bitter
[Applause]
so
to quote one worker they were confronted
when they got their coffee with a sign
and a woman yelling at us that the
coffee was no longer complimentary a
woman yelling at them judge I didn't
know you spend your mornings at Goldman
Sachs
anyway the anonymous Banker goes on
quote we had to go to the checkout
counter before we could leave I paid 299
this morning for cup of Seattle's best
well I assume they're either talking
about coffee or a urine sample from
Kelsey Grammer
he's clean now but come on people what's
with the whining you don't have to buy
coffee you can make your own or choose
to not drink it it's not like the
Gutfeld pay toilets at the studio where
the audience has no choice
and man if I cleaned up on that even if
I don't clean them
but look no one's forcing you to work
there you're not chained to your desk
like cat and that's for her own
well-being
but caffeine may be the least of their
worries as many as four thousand low
performing employees eight percent of
the Goldman Workforce could potentially
be laid off so they might as well buy
the coffee then at least they already
have a cup for people to drop change
into
that was mean
I actually feel bad for them but this is
happening to everyone not just wall
streeters so many Americans are dealing
with inflation in an uncertain future
and for that misery of course you can
thank Joe Biden's America am I right
people
that's what you call a desperate attempt
for red meat Applause
that meat was redder than a baboon's ass
during mating season
but I'm not totally heartless regardless
of what my four homeless estranged
children have to say the rich have
feelings too and I should know the price
of helicopter fuel is driving me insane
worse I now have to fill the tank myself
after letting kill Mead go
and he could pack a lot of tears under
those jaunty eyebrows
but this is what happens when Good Times
suddenly become bad all those perks seem
to vanish faster than a CNN anchor what
freebies that were once dangled in front
of you to join the firm disappear like a
garbage bag full of eclairs during the
views feeding time
ah
but
it's like Sea World but we're all
experienced
but we're all
experiencing this malaise before the
media would ignore it the politicians
would deny it and when it got undeniably
worse the press and politicians would
collude and tell us that inflation's
actually a good thing which is like
saying coven's a good thing or high
crime is a good thing in fact now that I
think of it pretty sure they did say
that
I asked for Goldman Sachs a company
that's already dealing with lower
revenues in this uncertain economic
climate co-workers claim that the free
coffee was the last straw
which sucks because that straw was going
to be safe for the blow
[Applause]
he brought back hanging for parking
violations co-host of the five-time
Janine Vera
if he looks like a guy who's a comedian
and owns a sandwich shop that's because
he is a comedian who owns a sandwich
shop Joe DeRosa
foreign
after a party people say what a mess Fox
News contributor cartoon
and finally he's got a gold chain and a
silver tongue my massive sidekick in the
nwa's World Heavyweight Champion Taurus
judge
what welcome to the show it's always a
pleasure you're like an ex-wife I never
had yeah yeah never wanted yes I feel
like I feel like Oscar from The Odd
Couple talking to was divorced but I
can't remember who played that it was
like that and Mira I don't know you're
older than I am I do think I would
remember I think it was Anne Meera
wasn't it wasn't it just a phone wasn't
it two guys yes it was Felix Unger what
did Anne mirror act he had an ex-wife
remember to get kicked out no I started
the garage there were two guys oh you
never saw Oscar's wife she just called
and asked for money really yeah why do I
have you know what this is a recovered
memory a false memory you're the only
person I've ever met more passionate
about The Odd Couple sitcom than the
movie yes yeah so I don't know and more
and more passionate about that than this
topic what's your question
[Laughter]
does this
we feel bad for the stock Brokers or is
this just a sign of America in general
that everybody's Facing The Chopping
Block well first of all the economy is
in the tank all right everybody knows
that by the way the audience reacted to
Joe Biden but who gets free anything
anymore unless it's from the government
if the government gives it to you then
everybody's got open arms but I I
honestly when I worked in government
nobody got free coffee we didn't have
anything free and now they're upset they
don't have their free latte schmates
whatever the hell they it is that they
drink you know too bad suck it up
we had a lot of freebies in TV people
send us stuff
someone will send you ribs it's
disgusting and we act like it's bad but
we'll do it because we're cheap bastards
Joe yes you own obviously uh you're a
new owner of a sub shop how is it how
are the prices on your subs because I go
to unbeatable
unbeatable or unmetable but no very
meaty very meaty they're delicious yeah
I tell you I was mad you didn't bring it
thank you phenomenal thank you I had to
say before the show I had to stop
bringing Hoagies to places because I
have shows that I need to sell tickets
we're on the Lower East Side it's called
Joey roses on Rivington Street
come down it's not free
oh sorry what uh
you would know but a oh I
I live near Jersey Mike's no offense I
bought a large sub it was twenty dollars
we used to talk about restaurants that
had burgers for 20 bucks as being
outrageous now that's the norm yeah we
no we we actually built our price list
during the lockdown when we were
developing the place and we said well
when everything opens we want to be able
to give New York something that has old
school New York prices and uh you know
you feel that a little bit now
that it's not locked out anymore but
we're sticking to it because you know we
want to try to give back a little bit uh
you gotta you gotta the thing that kills
me with this story is it's not people
complaining about the price of something
going up they're complaining about
something free yes being taken away
which is it's like when people complain
that your podcast says too many
commercials in it you know what I mean
you're not paying for it yeah exactly it
was free also I don't understand what
people or where they're going this is
the last straw we're about to get laid
off well what do you think is going to
happen before lay off do you think
they're going to start giving you things
they're cutting back yes and they're
also trying to dull you from caffeine so
you're not seeing that that ax coming
you know what I'm saying like I don't
understand what they thought was going
to happen layoffs are on the way why
aren't they giving us presents now that
somehow a layoff work yeah it's not like
a last meal right
[Laughter]
I don't know what that means cat do you
feel bad I feel bad for anybody who's
getting fired yes by the way you have to
we can talk after the show
that was a joke she's a prized employee
are you okay
yeah I don't I don't know I don't know a
lot about banking even though I live
with a banker because I'm married to him
yeah uh it just still seems like a lot
of charts and graphs and wearing a
headset and yeah like this
[Laughter]
so we like never talk
um so he drinks a lot of coffee so I
could see how that would be annoying but
again annoying like all of course the
free coffee sucks I don't think they're
really missing it that much and maybe
it's a trick maybe they're trying to see
who acts like a dick about the free
coffee and then they fire those people
that's what I would do if I ran a
company just be full of Tricks yeah
exactly and that would be every day is a
little scientific experiment like yeah
like a sociological experiment what if
every day I insult one of my panelists
over and over again what would happen
I'll tell you what happened you do it to
me
thank you
[Applause]
yeah I'm still sitting here and I never
get any free food it's always cat eat a
cheeseburger not cat here is a
cheeseburger that's true somebody sent
her a cheeseburger yeah I'll eat it all
right what's your take on this well I
think this is the desperate attempt of
one decent person in management trying
to cut costs instead of cutting
employees but that's a good point but
what's ugly about this is yeah that's
right you didn't expect that did you
because
our government knew this was coming see
these big companies can lay off they can
make Cuts they can downsize and they can
keep going
you can't sit at your breakfast table
and be like all right kids
uh someone's getting laid off today
uh which one of you has the lowest
grades yeah
sorry Cindy
please uh your mom will show you out you
know you can't
and if things pick up if uh daddy gets a
special or something we'll give you a
call yeah
love you it's true sea turtle no you
can't do that but what did we do during
Christmas
all the commercials were by this Black
Friday this spend your money get your
last gifts the media is covering all
this stuff to tell us to go shopping
knowing this is looming so now people
are losing jobs their savings gone
because and it's always right after
Christmas right after spending because
all the big markets they got their money
now can what can we cut so we can we can
make this last so yeah no one listen
like and and it drives me crazy because
it's across the board mainstream media
loves to tell you to spend and then now
they're going to go after a story like
this to be like oh how dare they cut
coffee fool they cut your paycheck yeah
so good luck with that excellent point I
learned a lot just now
can we lay off kids I don't know that'd
be awesome you're fired that's a great
show
call it baby Apprentice yeah oh you
gotta lay off one of your one of your
poodles I could host baby Apprentice you
could because I'd be good I'm taller I'd
be I could look down at the little
children
and you like making people cry love it I
would love this we okay whoever uh Chuck
with a producer of Celebrity Apprentice
baby Apprentice I'm no hosts
so they can beg for their job exactly
by the way can I just say the coffee
price
2.99. that's still an amazing deal it is
it is coffee is like 450 a cup yeah it's
ten dollars for a gallon of milk in this
country right now that's phenomenal for
a cup of coffee yeah all right sorry to
bring us back yeah and you're on the
baby reality
yeah sorry the left back to Baby
Apprentice
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else